hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the 2020 Tata Steel chess
tournament it's all it is a ferocious
versus Vladislav Artemyev aka Chuck
Norris it's a really exciting game so
let's dive straight into it and I have
prepared the standings after round three
just so I don't forget so ali reza opens
with E for now we have c6 artemyev goes
for the caro-kann defense with d4 and d5
with E 5 now the advanced variation of
the caro-kann and now Bishop to f5
preparing term at the close the
structure with each six now that the
bishop is out of the cage with h4 now if
black isn't careful for example if you
close the closet with six too fast then
g4 bishop g6 and h5 traps the bishop so
you have to be careful Artemia pushes h5
and now c4 by ali riza now we have e six
and Knight to c3 or all standard stuff
with nice the e7 Knight the GTE too and
the Knights the b7 now we have Knight
the g3 pushing the bishop back and
Bishop to g6 now Bishop to g5 a nice
nice square for the bishop but
immediately unpinning Queen to b6
unpinning
with an attack on the pawn here and here
rook to c1 asking do you want to capture
the pawn now you could capture opponent
it has been played before it's nothing
special happens there should be three
Bishop captures Queen captures and the
game just continues captures captures
ninety five and the game goes on white
is down upon but blacks King is still in
the center of the board
and well you you I generally don't want
to play this with black unless you you
really enjoy positions like these
so after look c1 we have D captures on
c4 by artemiev and mount bushel captures
on c4 and now Knight to f5 offering a
trade here and the position has been
reached in 2018
she brought our masters tournament
between a matsutake and Maria Musa Chuck
where Knight captures an f5 was played
and suit off ski was able to win that
game with white but here we have castles
by all it is and it is a new move in the
position so already has a move 12 we
have a completely new game and here you
have to this
side what do you do okay we already said
that you're not interested in the pawn
maybe that would be a bit dangerous but
what about a nightcap Tresor Queen
captures what about the d4 pawn well
also very interesting stuff for example
if Queen captures on d4 then all there
is a prepared Knight the b5 it's a super
sneaky move the Queen is under attack
the knight is a threatening night the c7
checks so the point is after pawn
captures and Bishop captures you're down
a piece but only momentarily
you can never defend the night since the
bishop is covering the d8 square and
whatever you do doesn't really matter a
six of white we'll just trade characters
captures a bishop sorry capture sit with
the knight Bishop captures night with
check King captures and rook FD one now
picks up the knight and the game
continues and it's a really awkward
position for the black King so capturing
with the Queen will not do after castles
if Knight captures on d4 then Knight to
a4 and the Queen has to leave the
defense of the night here yeah well you
could trade nights but it still doesn't
work Queen a5 Queen captures on d4 Queen
captures on a4 but now rook C to D 1 and
you will again have huge problems here
there's a really no good way to unwind
here even if you move the knight you're
still getting checkmated for example
check the Queen cap the rook after
screen and rook to the 8th is now mate
again the the opera house mate if you
will so after this castles move art
image just continues with Bishop to e7
nicely developing now there already is a
threat of capturing here as the division
no longer guards the da square so early
riser now captures an f5 with Bishop
captures an f5 and now Bishop captures
on e7 King captures on e7 now the King
is in the center of the board no longer
able to castle and then now Queen to d2
just guarding the be to pawn developing
the Queen connecting rooks and our team
Eve goes back with the Queen Queen to d8
now if Queen g5 check you can just move
the King and already our team would be
offering a queen trade so Knights the d1
by Alireza they're preparing to ship the
night over to e3 we have night the b6
pushing the bishop back and now
night's the III before before moving the
bishop point being if Knight captures
and c4 with Czech Queen to b4 check and
now the king is stuck really stuck in
the center of the board King g8 Knight
captures in c4 with Knight to d6 coming
there is no good way to prevent this
it's just a dominant position for white
so after 93 we have King back the f8 but
timid and now Knight captures on f5 we
have he captures on f5 and only now
Bishop to b3 you want to preserve this
bishop as it's a really strong attacking
piece plus you want to bust open the
position with be 6 so we have Queen
captures on h4 by artemiev and it's it's
a really bold move grabbing a pawn like
this when your King is still stuck on f8
when you might consider moves like rook
to h6 to bring the rook into the game
and continue developing but okay our
tentative grabs the pawn rook Queen
captures on h4 and now you could go for
a 6 right away but ali reza decides to
prepare it rook after a 1 we have rope
to h6 now and now e 6 busting open the
position with F captors and e6 and
Bishop captures on e6 so it's really
important that this bishop controls this
diagonal if you allow the black King to
hide then then black will just be okay
but of course Ali Reza will do
everything he can not to allow that so
here you have to decide do you want the
part with the f5 pawn it's not easy to
leave it there I mean it's not easy to
defend for example if fluke f6 you're
gonna get Queen to b4 check and now you
really don't have any any good squares
this is everything is taken if you go
here you go in front of the rook
so King yet you can go go shove d5 check
a king to d8 now the Queen comes into
the attack we need 7 check King to see
it and now there should be 6 check black
no longer has any moves you have to
capture and now you part with the Queen
so that's that's what can happen if you
decides to defend your phone so here
artemiev decides the play actively he
plays the rook to e8 and gets the rook
into the game and now Bishop captures an
f5 just eliminated
that pawn we have rook captures anyone
rook captures anyone in the now Queen
back to d8 the to help out with the
defense and now Queen to d3 and this is
a this is a really strong move this is a
top move recommended by the engine as it
allows all sorts of ideas for white it
it prepares Bishop to g6 which is just
insane since it covers the eighth square
rope - eh we'll just win the game on the
spot
also if black defends against that ideas
like Quinta a three check fall by queen
capture Sunday seven are possible it's
just a very very very active square for
the Queen so we have kinked the f7 bar
ten years getting the King - well not a
safer Square but it is a square that
prevents Bishop to g6 so he he's trying
to use his King here better than King to
f7 was nice the d5 but it's not an easy
move to spot you have to allow Bishop g6
then Knight to f6 you block the the I
mean you are da square with your knight
but then you have Queen the a3 check
King to g8 and now Russia back to c2 and
the black king will be somewhat safer
although it will still be very hard for
for the rook to enter the game also
guarding these pawns will be not not so
easy so that's what our team you should
have gone for steams seems a bit more
sturdy than King to f7 but okay he
decides for King to f7 and now Queen to
f3 again threatening a lot of very nasty
discoveries so here again if you go rook
to f6 it's not possible because of Queen
to h5 check the rook is stuck there
guarding the h5 pawn and here you're
just getting made King G a trochee a
check wins the Queen and very quickly
mates the black King so Timmy goes Queen
to f6 now there are no good discoveries
but you have Queen to b3 check another
option was ripped ecigs just kicking the
Queen away from there
but after Queen to g5 you don't really
have any good discoveries and still the
king will hide on g8 you you cannot move
the bishop since King captures rook on
d6 and
well there just aren't any good
discoveries white is still winning here
of course but it's not easy to calculate
so all the rest goes Queen to b3 check
instead keep the f8 and now Queen the a3
with check so what do you do here
problem is if you move the King with the
King to g8 then look the EI to check and
that's just it King to f7 raka fate is
mate if you move the King for example to
f7 it's not much better just Bishop to
e6 check King g6 and now Queen to d3
with check King g5 and Queen to g3 will
be made so you cannot move the king you
have to block with the Queen now that
the route can support the Queen Queen to
d6 and now of course not trading Queen's
Queen back to e3 now threatening Queen
to eight mate so our team of course
defense Queen to d8 and then now Queen
to efore again Alireza sticks to the
plan we have to put the bishop on g6 and
then deliver mate
so roof to f6 finally this rook can now
enter the game as there is no immediate
threat of losing the h5 pawn bishop to
g6 and again you have to be very careful
if you don't prevent it Quinta EA the
Queen captures and the rook captures
will be made so King to g8 and this
prevents mate now if if you attempt this
captures captures captures then you can
just block with the rook and what will
still be better but you don't you do not
want to give up your advantage away like
that
so Queen to h4 not allowing captures
because of captures and asking black
what do you want to do and of course you
are ready to capture here and deliver
Queen to h7 check so Queen to d5 now
guarding the pawn so if Queen captures
you can trade Queens so rook to e8 check
now by Alireza we wrote back to f8 and
now Queen to e7 preparing to capture
here you cannot trade because it's made
so Knight to d7 guarding the rook and
here's a here's a well a very important
position so what would you play here
feel free to pause the video and
continue the attack with white while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the the only
good attacking move for white and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
its verse should be back to see - yes
with the idea of Bishop to b3 winning
the Queen and the game so this is what
our days of course played artemyev
capture Tandy for getting rid of this
this threat here and now again ala Reza
continued with rook captures on a fade
but there was the Quinta East extract
move disk this seems to be winning on
the spot after King to h8 now Bishop to
f5 and the black doesn't have a move
because this piece is hanging and you
don't really you don't really have a way
of getting out of that you cannot move
the knight because just rook captures
rook and lastly if you capture capture
this just runs into mate so Quinta east
six much deadlier than the move out
there is a plate but all addresses move
just wins that wins a piece and goes
into a winning endgame so that that also
works rook captures anti-fade was played
by ali reza Knight captures on f8 and
now Bishop to b3 check removing the
defender of the knight King to h7 and
now Queen captures on f8 Artemyev
character than b2 and now push up the g8
with check King h6 and now Queen to f4
with check and here Alireza mate is move
40 so artemyev has to make one more move
to reach time control and he's extremely
low on time and it's a good thing he
played the g5 if you move the King you
are getting made it right away because
the bishop f7 check King has to move
Queen to f5 check and now well if you
move just Queen h5 is made to how to
play g6 captures King h8 and now Queen
to g8 will be made so after the screen
to inform you of course our team has
played the g5 but now Queen to d6 with
check King g7 and now Bishop back to b3
so how do you win this well it's it's
actually not that difficult
artemiy played Queen a1 check we have
King 2 h2 and now Queen back to f6 it's
artemyev who offers the Queen trade
because if he doesn't if he just waits
it's well Queen to e7 check King to h6
and now Bush of the f7 will create a
very very nasty mating net around the
black king so it doesn't really matter
h4 you were gonna go Quinta a6 check
King g7 now Queen g6 checking the faith
Queen g8 check King e7 and now Quinta eh
check where King to f6 is impossible
because of Quinta h8 picking up the
Queen and c3 so you have to go back but
now I just go Queen d8 check and after
lesyk King here you're gonna pick up
this pawn with check they're gonna pick
up this pawn and slowly but surely you
will well just just easily win the game
so here Artemyev offers a queen trade
and he hopes to survive this endgame
being down a piece but he's up to pawns
so all it is a trades Bishop Queen
captures on f6 King characters and now
kinked the g3 starts the ring in the
King into the game with b5 by Artemis
and Bishop to d1 now goes after the pawn
with H for check King g4 and now c5 all
that as it was for f4 destroys the
black's pawn structure on the King said
G captures a net foreign King captures
on f4 and here artemyev went into a
really really long thing maybe 35
minutes maybe even 40 I stopped checking
after I think after 35 but it was a
really long thing and he came again very
long time even after reaching time
control so he again reached some three
minutes on the clock for a solid as I
think had like 45 or something but
either way he went for King to e6 he has
to decide whether to start pushing right
away or kink to e6 king te vi it's it's
a good move as any because no moves are
good here for black since King to g4 we
have a five now and the King captures on
h4 with a four and now G for all that is
it starts pushing his passport and here
you have to decide what to do artemiy
played c4 the problem with a three you
will not get a chance to create a
blockade on the light squares to push b3
and then a sacrifice upon and go a 3
because g5 before you're gonna go King
age 5 c4 and now g6 but after b3 you
always have this
Bishop to e2 move and this is what ruins
blacks plan so now if you capture Bishop
captures with check picks up the pawn on
a - so there's no game there but if b2
still just captures with check King
moves and now Bishop here again guards
the queening square so everything is
everything is alright for white
so after g4c four by artemyev now he
will try to play a 3 and B 4 but just g5
viola days with a 3 and now Bishop to e2
keeping an eye on those pawns so you can
never push this guy here and if you push
this guy didn't just Bishop to d3 again
covers all the squares not a problem
so King if I was played but now King h5
with King efore but now g6 c3 now of
course offering this for for c2 all eras
are not interested Bishop to be 1 and
here there's just no way to cross the
light squares here Artemyev played King
to d5 but also it was in this position
on more 57 that Ladislav Artemia
resigned the game and yet another
victory for our recipe Rosa so he wins
both of his games with white and he has
a draw with black and with this victory
he takes the lead in the tournament
which we will show now as we do have the
standings about to just show a few more
moves let's say Bishop e3 check prevents
all contra play from black also regards
the queening square it's unnecessary but
you know still King b3 you can bring a
queen into the game c2 now just let's
say check captures with check and there
there's nothing to do here
so of course artemiy resigned and these
are the standings after three rounds so
other a sefolosha are still playing
under feed a flag first with two out of
three followed by four people with two
points Geoffrey Chien Wesley so Fabiano
Caruana and jordan van forest then would
one and a half point onigiri Magnus
cross and young Kristoff Duda Vladislav
artemiev Daniel dubov and with one point
Nikita with you gov Andrew Shana
tournament and also with half a point
you yongi end of lies love Kovalev so
those are the standings at around 3
we're gonna check out at least one more
game from round 3 tomorrow morning or
you know maybe before before afternoon
but the
definitely we're gonna check out one
more game as a lot of games were
decisive so now that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it excellent start for
a furrow sure he still didn't get to
play against well artemyev canst can be
considered an elite player definitely
but he still has to face the likes of
Magnus Corwin obviously so on and really
cement his lead but still he's in the
lead and it will put pressure on the
other players to start the winning games
with him now once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank I wish
tax calculator in Excel for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
twenty20 Tata Steel masters edition
maybe a few games from the challengers
edition if some are really good
continuing the coverage of the Women's
World Chess Championship and of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day